hi there steve coffin here today i want
to talk about
easy language learning now if you enjoy
these
uh videos about language learning please
subscribe to my channel
language learning is not easy it's not
easy because we have to force our brain
to become accustomed to a new way of
saying things new sounds new structures
new
ways that words are put together
this is not easy it's actually a
quite a complex process i believe having
gone through it many times where we
transform ourselves into
natural speakers of another language so
the whole process is not easy
however the things that we do
to help us get there we can choose to do
things that are inherently difficult
demanding stressful or we can choose to
do things that are easy
i prefer to do things that are easy
for example i find listening and reading
more enjoyable and therefore easier than
doing drills and exercises
i find that doing translation
is difficult whereas just allowing the
language to come into you is easier
when i do flashcards or
any of the activities that we have at
link which include closed tests and
multiple choice i want them to be easy
i'm just kind of flipping through these
words it's another
form of exposure to these new words i
don't want to be racking my brain trying
to think what does this
word mean
uh
you know when i when i uh for example
the
living language book that i occasionally
go to you know they'll introduce um
colors or
numbers
or um
you know names of members of your family
or verb endings and then they
immediately want to test you on it i
don't do these tests because i don't
find that easy
in fact it's very difficult to remember
something that you've just read on or
read about in the chapter it's going to
take a lot more exposure before you can
remember any of this so i don't want to
be tested on it what i find
easy for example is
using my ipad
and reading the variety of beginner
material that we have at link for
example
where i can
you know
basically simply touch words
and hear them pronounced or i can touch
phrases
and so as i'm reading through either
material that i've read before
or new stories that i haven't read and
as i save new words
and create new phrases and highlight
them or look at words and phrases that
were saved before i always get to hear
them and so it's actually a
spectacularly
easy way of plowing through
new texts
and yet listening to bits and pieces as
you read through i find that easy
uh
what else i tried to i was gonna in fact
i will be doing
an in-depth
review of duolingo so i thought i'd give
it a try i went on
in greek
and very quickly they asked you to
translate from english to greek so i've
got to
set up a keyboard and write in greek
which i don't want to do so i'm out of
there
then i thought well i'll do it with an
easier language that i haven't learned
before like dutch where i can at least
type in the uh
you know roman alphabet but even there
it's it's not something that i want to
be doing it's not easy for me i prefer
doing easy things exposure
as i say when i flash card i want all
the results on the front
i don't rack my brain
and so so this is kind of and i've
always felt this way about language
learning when i wrote my book 10 years
ago i had this
taoist
parable about the tree doing things that
are natural doing things that are easy
effortless following your nature
following your interest
that was a symbol that was the
first sort of introduction that i used
and i very much believe this and if we
are able
to uh oh another thing that i find easy
is
varying the content so rather than
forcing yourself to stay on on one
course chapter one two three i find that
by chapter three i'm bored with this and
i prefer to go and do another chapter
one two three of easy material and that
all so i'm exploring it and helped by
the text to speech and all of that is
easy and enjoyable
and i find gets you there
as quickly or more quickly than the sort
of forced
learning that's a part of traditional
instruction so there you have it
language learning isn't easy
but
we can choose to do things that are
enjoyable and easy and not place
unnecessary strain on ourselves and i
think that keeps us going with the
language and that we learn it
naturally and
in my opinion more effectively that way
than in a more stressful and less easy
way so i look forward to hearing your
comments
[Music]
you